hello everyone and welcome to round six
of this year's Tata steel Chess Masters
it is ala fua with the wi pieces against
Wei and we is coming off um from a short
draw in the previous round against n
katov and alira lost to women's world
champion jenu and if you haven't seen
that game uh do check it out really a
wonderful wonderful game first link in
the description below uh but now let's
see what happened in this one and of
course I will cover some other games
from the round as well alira with the
white pieces over opens with Pawn to D4
we have Knight to F6 uh Pawn to C4 E6
Knight to F3 and pawn to D5 the Queen's
gamb be declined is on the board we have
Knight to C3 and pawn to C5 uh offering
to go for C captures on D5 but here ala
goes for the more Cal approach he plays
Pawn to E3 uh and now D captures and C4
we have Bishop captures and C4 and now
just Pawn to A6 so just a a classical
way of playing the The Queen's Gambit
accepted uh we have Bishop to D3 going
back with the bishop and now Knight B to
D7 we have Queen to E2 and already it is
now as of move eight that we have a
completely new game this early Retreat
of the bishop unprovoked without playing
Black playing Pawn to B5 uh was rare but
connecting with Queen to E2 is uh well
it has just never been played before so
let's see how he deals with this he
plays Pawn to B5 as a you know it's
pretty pretty standard way of developing
we have castles and Bishop to B7 we have
Rook to D1 nicely aligning The Rook with
the black queen uh and the bishop to D6
so okay D captures and C5 we have bishop
captur and C5 and just Pawn to H3 uh
Way's Bishops are placed very nicely
going after ala's King we have castles
uh and now Pawn to E4 grabbing more
space in the center we have Queen to C7
and now Bishop to E3 E5 would be a bit
premature because um well way can just
remove one of the Defenders of E5 and
then grab the grab the pawn so instead
just Bishop to E3 and here Rook 8 to C8
way continues development we have Rook
eight to C1 and now Bishop captures an
E3 Queen captures and queen to B6 we
offers a trade of Queens so it is a says
all right we might trade Queens but
first I will improve the position of my
knight we have Knight to D4 and now
Knight to E5 attacking the bishop on D3
so Bishop back to E2 and now Rook F to
d8 and way and ala both uh well pretty
much fully completed their development
uh Pawn to F3 strengthening the E4 Pawn
uh but while doing so you do create some
dark Square issues so here uh way he
tries to take advantage of that he plays
Pawn to H5 uh King to F2 now the Knight
can move as the queen on E3 will not
hang uh and pawn to H4 uh we have Knight
to B3 now offering a trade of Queens as
he might um uh soon find his King in an
unfavor unfavorable situation uh Queen
captures on E3 with check King captures
and now Pawn to G5 so grabbing hold of
the king side uh and way he says all
right I like my position uh I don't
think you have anything with white here
but alza finds something very tricky he
plays Rook captures on d8 Rook captures
on d8 and now Knight to C5 attacking the
bishop and if the bishop moves also
maybe attacking the A6 Pawn for example
if you go to A8 so Bishop to C8 was
played and now just Pawn to A4 making
life very very hard for we the problem
is uh there's no good reply here uh you
can't really push B4 you can't capture
on A4 I mean you can but if you play B4
then Knight A2 attacks the pawn and once
you defend it then Knight to B3 attacks
the A5 pawn and there's no way of
defending the A5 Pawn now so here you
could capture but then okay Knight Will
capture and the A6 will be will be very
weak the The Rook will be able to go
after the pawn here so Knight F to D7
was played it is in fact the top move
recommended by the engine and ala claims
the the pawn Knight captures on D7
Bishop captures we have a captures a
captures and now Knight captures on B5
so ala wins a pawn and it's a past B
Pawn and uh well we could definitely
consider capturing the Knight here uh
idea being that if captures captures now
okay ala is up a pawn but he has a light
Square Bishop all of his pawns are on
light squares uh the Knight on E5 is a
is a just a monster Knight a beautiful
piece cannot be opposed by the bishop so
uh definitely something to consider and
of course Wei did consider it but he
decided against it he played Knight to
G6 the Knight can now be put to F4 if
needed maybe even H5 and G3 uh although
there's still too much in play to just
land the Knight on G3 there's the The
Rook to pass B Pawn and so on so Rook to
D1 is played preventing the Bishop from
moving now King to f8 way he needs to
bring the The Rook to help out with the
defense of the Rook before moving the
bishop or defend the the bishop while
moving The Rook so Pawn to B E4 King to
E7 and now Knight back to C3 the pass
Pawn is now ready to March forward uh
Rook to C8 and just King to D2 We have
Knight to E5 uh and now Pawn to B5
advancing the past Pawn King to D6 now
even going in front of the white Rook uh
but he will be able to defend the pawn
with his King so King to C2 with a
discovered check King to C7 and now King
to B3 we have Rook to B8 putting
pressure on the B Pawn but is very well
defended by the Knight by the bishop uh
and of course by the king king to B4 we
have Bishop to E8 uh and now Knight to
A4 uh we have Knight to C6 with check
forcing the king back covering the A5
Square King to C5 and now Knight to E5
looking for some other checks Knight to
D7 check will also Force the white king
back so Rook to C1 uh if the white king
moves he will threaten some nasty
discoveries here Rook to d8 and now King
back to B4 with check the king now has
to move King B7 and now Rook to C5
putting pressure on the Knight and okay
this is move 41 the time control has
been reached we had some two minutes on
the clock when he reached time control
and now the question is do you move the
Knight and give up the G5 Pawn or do you
defend the knight in the game way
defended the knight uh the engine says
that you should play Knight G6 and give
up the pawn but I mean even this looks
um uh lost just Rook D2 and of course
the the engine favors activity now ala
would be up two pawns but he would have
an active Rook so maybe you know a
better way to go than uh we is Pawn to
F6 he does keep material but his
position is very passive we have Rook
back to C2 stopping Rook to D2 but also
freeing up the C5 Square uh for the for
the Knight as the E6 Pawn has been
weakened Knight to C5 check will pick up
the E6 Pawn so Rook to D6 way ye defends
it and now just King to A5 ala brings
the king in to help help out with the
escorting of the pawn pawn to F5 and now
Knight to C5 with check we have King A7
and now alza plays Knight to A6 here he
had to do a little bit of calculating
because there's this very cool trick of
Rook captures on A6 uh it just doesn't
work the problem is that after Pawn
captures there's this Knight to C6 with
check and now if you go back with the
King which is sort of your only move
with the King you go under the mask of
the bishop and then Knight to D4 with
check will pick up the Rook on C1 on C2
but you can capture on C6 with the rook
and after Bishop captures you just play
Bishop to B5 and your extra Pawn is of
course winning um no worries there
especially since the pawn is queening on
a light Square you have a light Square
Bishop uh more more so and if Bishop to8
you will move the bishop back to D3 and
this is an elementary uh you know uh end
game where you are winning the end game
of Bishops of the same color where you
are up a pawn so instead after Knight A6
Bishop to D7 was played and here alza
did take his time I think he maybe even
took 20 minutes here in this position
because pretty much every move is
winning for white but you also want to
make it a precise one he just played e
captures on F5 and he was in this
position on move 46 that way resigned
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here of course you could still play
it a little bit and uh you know if he
really wanted to he could but he of
course uh knows that ala is incredibly
strong and that chances are that he will
not make a mistake here so if you guys
are interested of course I will show uh
how you could also win this for example
uh of course he will win win back the
pawn now some Rook to C7 check you want
to go to C5 but it's important to be
precise uh you kick away the black king
in the corner it's the only move the
black king has and now you play Pawn to
C5 much better than having the black
king on A7 so you put pressure on the
Knight and now it doesn't matter if the
Knight moves to to D3 you just capture
it with the bishop but black is in no
position to trade pieces and if you go
to F7 then Bishop to C4 threatening
Bishop to D5 check for example Knight to
d8 Bishop to D5 check Knight to B7
blocking check also delivering a check
to the white king and I just Bishop
captures on B7 King captures on B7 and
now Rook to C7 with check King A8 and
pawn to B6 Rook D5 check for example
Knight to C5 will block check go after
the bishop here and after King to B8 you
can even trade Rook captures Rook
captures King to A6 and now of course
this is a very very strong threat The
Rook will have to go back you will
capture and then King A7 just escorts
the pawn up the board so Rook to C8 will
have to be played but again uh we we
we're going to be precise Rook B7 check
King to A8 and now Rook G7 threatening
B7 check and also just picking up all of
the pawns on the king side uh from here
it's fairly fairly simple uh so yeah
after he captures on F5 we he had enough
and he said all right you you aler take
the full
point and you know it's a it's a good
way to bounce back he lost the previous
game to jenu like I said if you haven't
seen it first l in the description below
but now he bounces back and Anish giri
was still playing his game so I don't
know the the exact standings I could
check now uh so if you're not interested
in results of the other games you know
stop the video now uh but yeah I will
check uh just to check up on okay Anish
and param are still playing it's rook
and pawn versus rook and pawn yeah
they're still still going hard at it uh
but yeah Max farmer defeated donchenko
ding Drew uh with abdat of ala defeated
we we've seen that nepo Drew against
Prana that was also a very interesting
game Jordan pest lost to GES and women's
world champion
jujun well a fair fairly early draw to
visit guati uh so if you have any uh
favorites do hasht suggestion but I will
show at least one more game from round
six of this year's tataa steel Masters
and then we're going to discuss the
standings and you know everything fun
that happened maybe check out a few
photos uh and so on uh so yeah uh that's
the game hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank Mark Henley Brandon Brian
pin Johan Clon Lyn Herbert and
Christopher and Ru brette for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day